so of all the movies that Pixar has
there making a sequel to cars
I find that weird why do I find that
weird I don't know cars - alright so
it's safe to say that Pixar is known for
making movies that both adults and kids
both know love and relate to now in my
experience there are two kinds of people
in the world people who see cars is like
the least favorite of the Pixar movies
and people who don't how did they do
with cars - the main character in cars -
is not mr. hot rod red car otherwise
known as the car in the forefront of the
poster now it's actually the Larry the
Cable Guy tow truck and I for one I'm
not a Larry the Cable Guy kind of guy
you know the whole Gator Dan not my
thing
warning if you comment get or done
anywhere in this video in that fortune
cookie kind of way 2011 will be the year
of hell for you just saying Karma's a
but in cars - it really doesn't revolve
around the racing there's a Racing Grand
Prix going on but that's not the point
of this movie it's this whole spy
espionage thing going on however the
racing that it did show was really cool
aiming that spy kind of way it has some
really cool fun spy stuff for following
up Toy Story 3 with cars - is like
following mario 64 with Luigi's Mansion
you can't do that just it's just not
smart and I don't know if I can call it
a comedy because I didn't really laugh a
lot if you like the bumbling Larry the
Cable Guy type character they'll
probably laugh in the movie I enjoyed
seeing the satire car versions of things
that we have in our world in their world
that was pretty funny but for me you
know how every Pixar movie has that five
minute short at the beginning the five
minute Toy Story short made me laugh out
loud first - chuckle so although Cars 2
is a family movie and kids will really
enjoy it it's not going to be like 90%
of the other Pixar movies where adults
are like dude that is awesome Cars 2
will not be in the running at the end of
the year for best movie of the year it
is below average for a Pixar movie and
it's actually below average in terms of
animated movies that have come out in
the past year like tangled Megamind Toy
Story 3 goes without saying I'm not even
going to say that How to Train Your
Dragon all a lot better than cars - I
feel like Cars 2 would have been
enjoyable if it wasn't Pixar but
unfortunately since Pixar always
releases just these really really good
movies and set the bar so high in the
past decade and a half it just falls
short if you have a family and you're
looking for a kids movie that the kids
will enjoy or you're a kid yourself
you'll enjoy cars - if you're looking
for anything more if you're looking for
that Pixar magic it's not really in this
movie think of it this way
think of an average spy type comedy in
which a bumbling person gets wrapped up
in spy espionage stuff now if you take
Cars 2 and you replace the cars with
people and strip away the family element
in the Pixar paint you'll probably have
the movie you just thought of so as for
me I'll say it's okay but you're not
going to remember it in t-minus one day
they'll make their money back in the
merchandising it doesn't matter
merchandising we're the real money from
the movie is made yogurts baseballs so
your favorite Pixar movie of all time
other than Toy Story 3 in fact other
than any of the toy stories it's almost
like a cheat saying Toy Story so other
than that comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more